hello my name is Adam Forney and I'm a
researcher at Microsoft Research and
I'll be demoing today verse which is
short for voice exploration retrieval
and search and its joint work with
Alexandre Victoriana Meredith Ringgold
Morris Lea Finley later and Ryan White
and the idea of this demo is really
really simple it's that we want to take
a virtual assistant like Cortana
or Alexa and add to it some capabilities
that are typically available in screen
readers which are accessibility tools
that blind individuals use to access
online content now the motivation for
this project is also fairly
straightforward we conducted a large
series of surveys and interviews of
people who are screen reader users
people are visually impaired and we ask
them how are you accessing online
content on a day to day basis and of
course they're using web browsers and
screen readers but increasingly they're
also telling us that they're making
extensive use of virtual assistants
virtual assistants actually have a
number of advantages for this community
they primarily conduct all the
interactions through the audio channel
everybody experiences them the same way
so they tend to be accessible almost by
accident but they also have a number of
disadvantages for this community who are
expert users of audio interfaces virtual
assistants they speak much slower than
screen reader and they are they tend to
be a much more shallow they might give
you the first search result or they
might read you the first paragraph of a
Wikipedia article but that's really just
scratching the surface of what expert
audio interface users can achieve with
such systems all right so I'll give you
a brief demo of our of our system verse
I'm going to use the microphone on this
headset in order to provide input but
you can imagine that this experience
would work on a smart speaker as well so
to begin the interaction I will just
speak a query similar to what I might
ask Alexa or Cortana so I might say what
is Microsoft Research Microsoft research
is the research subsidiary of Microsoft
it was formed in 1991 now that's a
fairly low rate of speech but the answer
is comparable to what you would get from
a smart speaker I'd like the agent to
speak a little faster so I can say speak
faster okay I increased my speech rate
my speech rate now he's one point five
all right so now I can ask that question
again I could say what is Microsoft
Research Microsoft research is the
research a subsidiary of Microsoft
I also found one entity ten webpages
eight related search queries 10 videos
10 wikipedia articles all right so at
this point we've got our fairly
straightforward answer but we also have
clues to what other content is out there
online so in this case I can see that
there are at least eight related
searches or 10 webpages so I could say
go to web results I found 10 webpages
the first one is Microsoft Research
emerging technology computers and
explore research and Microsoft aside
featuring the impact of research along
with publications products downloads and
research careers from
www.microsoft.com/mechanics twunt a next
page to Microsoft Research Wikipedia now
doing this all through voice can
actually is possible but it can be
fairly tedious so we've added additional
accelerators so for example I can use my
SmartWatch or my smartphone in order to
provide a shortcut so in this case just
scrolling the the wheel on my watch I
should be able to h3 scroll through the
page for Microsoft 3 page 5 page port
and I can age the same thing on my for
Microsoft 3 page 2 and I can engage that
article that's more like resolved
research use the research a subsidiary
on Microsoft so I could say open that
article read section headings
introduction section 1 key people
section 2 research areas section 3 and I
can go to a particular section go to
research areas ok here's the section
number 2 titled research areas Microsoft
Research is categorized into the
following broad areas algorithm so just
to summarize we're able to engage with
different search protocols we can engage
with content and we can
navigates using some of the same
techniques you would use to navigate if
you're using a screen reader so you can
navigate by section or by by headings in
this case but also by paragraphs or by
sentences or words and I can issue voice
commands or I can issue gestures on my
phone or on my watch that are that are
identical to those that an individual
using a screen reader would use on their
on their phone